from calorie count to portion sizes we
want to find out all the differences
between dunkin donuts haha
it's me okay i'll do it for real
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between dunkin donuts in the uk
and the us this is food wars
[Music]
dunkin donuts in the u.s you get your
donuts in three different
sizes i guess one donut
half a dozen donuts nice and of course
everyone's favorite dozen donuts
in the uk our donuts also come in three
quantities and shockingly it's the same
as in the states
you can get one donut a half dozen
donuts
or you can be the life of the party
with the full dozen and it's food wars
so you know
we're weighing a doughnut now let's see
how much a glazed doughnut weighs in the
uk
[Music]
our glaze doughnut came to pretty much
exactly 50 grams so it looks like the
states are getting a better deal
at a us dunkin donuts you can get your
munchkins in
four different units of munchkin
five munchkins dude
10 munchkins not enough
kick it up to 25 munchkins yeah
and if that isn't enough you can go all
the way
to 50 munchkins 50 of these things wow
look at the size of this
it's a lot of munchkins in the uk we
also have four units of munchkin
starting with four
from there we move upwards to
12 munchkins the next size up from 12
is in a box and the box contains
24 munchkins and finally our biggest
size of munchkins in the uk
is 50.
that might not make too much sense to
compare just one munchkin in the uk and
the us because i'm sure they're all
slightly different shapes and sizes
however what we could do is measure 24
munchkins here
and 24 mentions there and hope that it
provides a kind of overview of the
average weight
that sounds about right sounds like
science to me let's do it
all right this is 25 so i'm gonna take
one out oh
can i do it without spilling let's go
oh god
looking like
how is that so good okay munchkin
challenge number one
uh how many munchkins can i fit in my
mouth at one time
without dying
[Music]
can you hurry this up man we got other
stuff done
[Music]
for yes seven you were roughly right
because i feel like i started cheated
because i almost
died in the u.s dunkin donuts our hot
coffees come in four
sizes small in the uk our hot coffees
come in two sizes regular and large
large and
extra large the dunkin donuts u.s
website says that their large hot coffee
is 20 ounces
got a measuring cup here let's find out
if that is true now
full disclosure and the car head over
here had a little bit of a spillage
so i'm gonna give this one we'll say a
two ounce leeway
should be 20 ounces might be 18 mm
okay that's 16 four more ounces
give me a break that's
maybe an ounce 16 plus one i think is
still 17.
there is no way there is
this much of coffee in my car seat
let's generously add 2 16 17 18 19.
i don't want to be that generous wait a
second i got an idea 20 ounces so that
means i need four in here correct
okay that's 20 ounces
i'm gonna settle this right now
okay there's 16 in a cup
plus four you know what's about to
happen you ready
[Music]
come on now now that seems very dramatic
so i'm also gonna measure
our large coffee not black coffee did i
get that with milk i'm so stupid
i just remembered i put my milk in the
lodge so we're gonna measure anyway and
see what happens
looks pretty much exactly 16 ounces
iced coffees in the uk also come in two
sizes regular and large
at a dunkin donuts in the u.s we have
three iced coffee sizes
small yeah mediums and
the large needs like two ounces of
coffee
that's just too much 32 ounces do i have
enough for 32 ounces of 16 and this is
eight no i don't we're also going to
measure our large iced coffee to see
what it comes to
so a large iced coffee in the uk came to
18 ounces
since i don't have another 16 ounce
cup i will use this one
right on the 16th okay
that's one 16 ounce oh geez
this is exactly 16 ounces here was this
the large
this should be 16 more fluid ounces
shameful absolutely shameful
that there definitely was not this much
space left in the cup
27 and a half fluid ounces in your 32
ounce large iced coffee it's still
almost to the i mean our pa just pointed
out that maybe the density is different
right when you put exactly the most
frozen ice maybe
we'll let's ask someone who's a
scientist
no scientist but that won't change
everything and you guys are still kind
of getting a bit short-changed it's just
because the density of the
solid or the liquid might change the
actual amount of liquid in there is
still going to be the same so it should
all balance itself out eventually
at the u.s dunkin donuts the largest
single food item you can get is
this two dozen donuts and the largest
drink you can get
is a box of joe look at this i think
that's about a hundred
fluid ounces of coffee i've always
wanted to do this i mean it's like
really hot in here okay
just set this down in my seat and be
like this is my coffee
all right write my name right on it's
right there joe
do not touch what is it
oh yeah mine baby
mine oh man i've already drink way too
much coffee
[Laughter]
now the biggest thing on the menu in the
uk is the dunkin feast this is two dozen
donuts 50 munchkins and
two boxes of joe all for a price of 80
pounds
now unfortunately when we went in today
they didn't have any boxes of joe
available
however one of them is supposed to be
100 fluid ounces of coffee which is
far too much coffee
this here is a u.s glaze dunkin donut
donut it is
roughly 360 calories has 22 grams of fat
10 of those are saturated 420 milligrams
of sodium
39 carbs and 18 grams of sugar
and in the uk the same donut has 230
calories
13 grams of fat 230 milligrams of sodium
25 grams of carbs and 10 grams of sugar
so by my calculations the u.s glazed
donut is 56.5 percent higher in calories
69.2 percent higher in fat and 80
percent higher in sugar
i get a burp sorry let's talk about
another donut
the boston cream donut i don't know why
it's shaped like a heart i'm assuming
because it's valentine's we're shooting
this in february
normally it's a circle anyway this donut
has
270 calories 11 grams of fat
18 grams of sugar the uk version of the
boston cream contains 280 calories 15
grams of fat
17 grams of sugar so that has more
calories and fat
a large iced coffee with cream and sugar
in the u.s
has roughly 260
hang on
back to life baby a large iced coffee at
a dunkin donuts in the u.s has
260 calories 18 grams of fat and 37
grams of carbs that seems like a lot
doesn't it
in the uk a large dunking coffee with
cream and sugar comes to 190 calories
with 9.1 grams of fat
and 38.4 grams of carbs if we break it
down by fluid ounce
it turns out the us is higher in every
metric except
carbs just look at all that data think
about adding a flavor pump to your
coffee
in the u.s and the uk you can get
vanilla caramel hazelnut flavors
on average in the u.s though when you
add those pumps you are adding
calories 38 grams of carbs and 37
more grams of sugar all of our
information from the uk for this episode
was taken
from not dunkin donuts uk but other
nutrition sites and food bloggers and
whatever
assuming that the iced coffee in the u.s
and dunkin donuts are the same
not sure if it is they didn't tell us
thanks a lot dunkin donuts uk but
assuming it is the same
to get this large iced coffee with cream
and sugar and these two donuts we talked
about earlier
total it is 890 calories which is 35.6
of your daily intake and in the uk a
large iced coffee with cream and sugar
a glazed doughnut and a boston cream
donut comes to 700 calories or 28
of your daily allowance what about
munchkins in the u.s
one glazed munchkin is 60 calories it's
3 grams of fat
60 milligrams of sodium 7 grams of carbs
and 3 grams of sugar
now unfortunately duncan in the uk does
not release any of its ingredients
information we did reach out to see if
they make an exception but unfortunately
at the time of shooting this they had
not
us dunkin donuts website does have a
majority of its nutritional info on the
site let me read you some hits right now
okay first the coffee hot or cold it's
100
brewed arabica coffee fantastic now
if you want to add cream and sugar to
your coffee like a 16 year old
influencer
now you've added milk cream to sodium
phosphate as a stabilizer
sodium citrate as a stabilizer and sugar
of the many flavor shots you can add to
the coffee in the u.s i picked the
caramel one because it's also available
in the uk
assuming that it is the same in the us
and the uk in the u.s the caramel shots
are made up of
sweetened condensed non-fat milk which
is not fat milk and sugar
uh high fructose corn syrup and sugar
water
and brown sugar so three different
various sugar
substances fantastic caramel color
potassium sorbate is a preservative
natural flavors and salt a glazed donut
at a us dunkin donuts is made up of
enriched wheat flour which is flour
malted barley
okay niacin reduced iron thiamine mono
nitrate
riboflavin folic acid all right
water palm oil yeast donut concentrates
brackets which is
soy flour salt leavings sodium acid
pyrophosphate baking soda
wheat starch whey a milk derivative
non-fat dry milk gum blend
which is a cellulose gum guar gum acadia
gum
carrageenan and xantham gum
a lot of gum do you scroll please
sodium cassonate which is a milk
derivative
sodium sterile acetate less
lactolate and it contains two percent or
less of
soybean oil soy lecithin whole egg
natural flavors turmeric extract for
color enzymes
and nettle extract for color yeast
dextrose soybean oil
and mono and diglycerides okay that's
the dough
now for the glaze we ain't even done yet
scroll it please
the glaze of a glazed donut has sugar
water maltodextrin and contains two
percent or less
of cornstarch mono and diglycerides
citric acid
agar cellulose gum potassium sorbate as
a preservative
and of course artificial flavors it's a
lot of stuff
so what's in the boston cream donut you
ask all right the dough is the same as
the glazed dough but the bavarian cream
filling
is water sugar modified food starch
corn syrup palm oil and it contains two
percent or less of
sucrose esters natural and artificial
flavors
oh my god glucano delta
lacto i mean they're just making fun of
me at this point
glucano delta lactone
sounds like a font salt potassium
sorbate and
sodium benzonates for preservatives and
agar
and beta carotene for color and of
course
don't forget about the chocolate icing
which is sugar water cocoa
high fructose corn syrup soybean oil
corn starch
corn syrup maltodextrin it contains two
percent or less of
dextrose palm oil salt potassium sorbate
and sodium phonier preservatives soy
lecithin artificial flavors
and agar and you know what i'm not going
through every donut
here's everything exclusive to the u.s
at dunkin donuts here is everything you
will only find on the menu at a uk
dunkin donuts
i'm not sure if they have any bagels at
the uk dunkin donuts but in the u.s you
can get
cinnamon raisin you can get sesame
everything oh you can also get of course
english muffins
an english muffin how come england
doesn't have the english muffins
makes you wonder makes you wonder here
are all the exclusive donuts you can
only find in the uk
there are a lot of them and i've
forgotten all of their names so i'm just
gonna make up names for them as i go
and then we can put the actual names off
on screen for you let's start with this
one
this is sonic the hedgehog it's very
very bright if you
see something that's this color in
nature just do not eat it
this one i believe is mr happy little
smiley face
it's kind of cute or sinister perhaps
depending on
your interpretation of things
it's worth noting that some of these are
only here because we're filming this in
the run-up to valentine's day
so they've got a bit of a love theme
going on right now this one
is uh love dust flatline
pretty in pink heart bypass love
prison this is like jail cell bars
this one is um keith this one i'm jazzed
about this is the apple crumble donut
now i know american pie is a very
american thing whereas in the uk
we quite like a crumble instead of
pastry we have a kind of like
flour and butter crumble mix on top so
many different donuts than the us and
not in the uk
i didn't want to do every single donut
that's different but
three that i feel are like kind of like
the hits that i would figure were
everywhere but apparently not in the uk
are an old-fashioned this one right
apple fritter hang on
good in the coffee roll look at the size
of the sculptural man it's like a spare
tire
hell yeah a coffee cake muffin also in
the u.s you get corn muffins and some
dunkin donuts not the one that i went to
unfortunately
breakfast sandwiches dunkin donuts in
the u.s has so
many different varieties of sandwiches
far too many to mention in this
i got as many as i could find so one of
these is a turkey sausage egg and cheese
the other one is a beyond
meat breakfast sandwich these all look
the same
veggie egg white omelet sandwich
on the protein thins the power breakfast
sandwich
i don't know this one what is this
this one's got like some bacon and stuff
on it an egg white
with bacon sandwich on a croissant
here's just a few
other ones that are available in the us
and not in the uk that i couldn't get my
hands on
limited menu the belgian waffle
breakfast sandwich
uh maple sugar bacon big and toasty
angus steak sandwich
they also have chicken bacon sandwiches
a
chicken biscuit which i would love to
have had wasn't available
and of course their exclusive grilled
cheese
also they have snacking bacon and those
dunkin bowls i can't believe they didn't
have
like i got those just recently along
with bagels you can also get white
cheddar bagel twists and finally we have
a few other items that you will only
find in the uk
we'll start with these two cookies this
one is a chocolate chunk cookie
and this one is a salted caramel cookie
this one looks like aggressively salty
there's big
chunks of sand not sand salt
sand would be a gross cookie then we
have two exclusive hot coffee options
which are the cortado and the flat white
a cortado is a foamed milk and espresso
combination
and a flat white is a steamed milk and
espresso combination then we have a
couple of exclusive cold options as well
this one is a mango cool latte which is
like a mango flavored
kind of blended ice drink it looks
pretty good
can you imagine that being quite
refreshing on a summer's day and then
finally we have this which is a
shaken lemonade uh it kind of just looks
like water now i'm not sure if that's
just because it's been sat here for a
while under the lights
but it's quite impressive to watch the
lady make it in the shop she was
actually going out with a cocktail
shaker and it was a bit of fun
the drinks so many different drinks that
you can get
the u.s you can't get in the uk i'll
just start down here
first one iced cappuccino am i taking a
sip of everything
ice cappuccino that's all right
frozen chocolate iced americano
peach passion fruit refresher
a strawberry dragon fruit refresher the
only hot one we have here is a
matcha latte iced matcha latte ooh
we're talking about the culattas yo
culatas yeah strawberry kulana
oh a little tart i like that
conserving straws
yeah that oh that's the best one blue
raspberry blue
raspberry colada i love us on my high
horse about how sweet these beverages
are and how bad it is for him
culatas very nice a green culatta
that's something matcha i don't know
what that is there's matcha in it
and last but not least at least i don't
think okay
this is a milk colored culada
i can't imagine this being any good whoa
that's actually pretty good yeah it's
vanilla this is too much of any
and i would have a coolada if it came in
like three ounces just like a shot
whoever's still stuck around to watch
this i'm gonna try and fit a whole donut
in my mouth let's go
[Music]
subscribe to the food insider for more
nailed it
nailed it